You should have already
downloaded and installed
R on your computer.
If you have not downloaded
and installed R yet,
please follow the instructions
on the course website
before continuing
with this lecture.
Once you've installed R,
go ahead and start it.
You should see the R
console like we see here.
This is where we'll type
commands and perform
data analysis.
In this course, we'll mostly
be working in the R console,
but sometimes you'll
also want to use
what are known as
"script files."
We'll see an example
of how to use a script
file at the end of this lecture.
In your R console, you'll always
type commands after the arrow,
or "greater than" sign.
Let's start with some
basic calculations.
So with your cursor
at the arrow,
let's type 8, and then the
star symbol for "times,"
the number 6, and hit Enter.
You should see the
result 48, or 8 times 6.
In this way, R can be used
as a basic calculator.
We can perform many other
basic calculations, like 2,
"raised to the power," by typing
the carrot symbol, and then
the number 16,
and hitting Enter.
You should see the result
65,536-- or 2 the power 16.
Note that each of the results
here are labeled with a 1
in brackets.
This is just R's way
of labeling the output
and we can safely ignore it.
If you type something
in your R console
but don't finish it
properly-- for example,
try typing 2 and
the carrot symbol,
and hitting Enter-- R
will show you a plus sign
and will wait for you
to finish the command.
You can either finish the
command-- in this case,
by typing a number--
or you can hit Escape,
and R will take you
back to the arrow sign.
So if you ever see a plus
sign while working in R,
it means that R is waiting
for you to finish the line.
If you're not sure
how to finish it,
you can always just hit Escape.
A nice feature of
the R console is
that you can scroll through
your previous commands
by using the up and down
arrows on your keyboard.
If you hit the up
arrow three times,
you should go back to
the 8 times 6 command.
If you hit Enter, you can
run this command again.
You could also adjust
previous commands.
Hit the up arrow again to go
back to the 8 times 6 command.
This time, delete the 6,
type a 10, and hit Enter.
We'll use this
approach to re-run
or adjust commands many
times in this class.
Generally, R works in terms
of functions and variables.
A function can take in
several arguments, or inputs,
and returns an output value.
An example is the square
root, or sqrt, function.
In your R console,
type sqrt, and then
in parentheses, the
number 2, and hit Enter.
The function is sqrt, the input,
or argument, is the number 2,
and the output is 1.414214.
There are thousands of
functions in R. Some of them
are built into R--
like this one--
and some can be added in by
installing packages, which
we'll do several
times in this class.
Another example of a function
is the abs, or absolute value
function, which returns the
absolute value of a number.
So if we type abs and then
in parentheses negative 65
and hit Enter, we should get
the result 65 as our output.
You can get help on
any function in R
by typing a question mark
and then the function name.
So if we type ?sqrt
and hit Enter,
you should see the R Help
Page for the sqrt function.
The help pages are
often very useful,
and if you want to learn
more about a function,
you should refer to
the help page in R.
Now, get rid of the Help Page,
and go back to your R console.
Suppose we now want to save
the output of a function.
We can do this by
saving it to a variable.
In your R console, type
SquareRoot2 and then an
equals sign, and then sqrt, and
in parentheses the number 2.
And hit Enter.
Now you don't see
the output of sqrt(2)
because we saved it to the
variable named "SquareRoot2."
You can see the value of a
variable by typing its name
and hitting Enter.
So type SquareRoot2 exactly how
you typed it before, and hit
Enter.
You should see that it
takes the value 1.414214.
SquareRoot2 is a
name that we created,
and we could have named
it many other things.
Generally, you have
a lot of freedom
in naming your variables, but
there are a couple basic rules.
One is that you should not
use spaces in variable names.
If you want to easily separate
words in a variable name,
popular strategies are using
a mix of capital and lowercase
letters-- as we did
here-- or to separate
the words using periods.
Another basic rule is
that you should not
start variable
names with a number.
Keep in mind that variable
names in R are case-sensitive.
Capital and lowercase letters
are seen differently by R.
When we created our
variable SquareRoot2,
we used the equals
sign for assignment,
or to assign the
value of sqrt(2)
to the variable
named SquareRoot2.
You could instead use a
"less than" sign with a dash.
For example, let's create a
new variable called HoursYear,
and then type the less
than sign and a dash,
followed by 365 times 24.
If you hit Enter and then type
HoursYear to look at its value,
you should see 8,760-- or the
number of hours in a year.
By doing this, the less
than sign and the dash
did the exact same
thing as it would
have done if we used
the equals sign.
In this course, we'll
typically use the equals sign.
But if you see this less
than sign and a dash used,
keep in mind that it means the
same thing as an equals sign.
Lastly, if you type ls and then
empty parentheses in your R
console and hit
Enter, you should
see a list of all
of the variables
that you've created in
your current R session.
Here, we've created
two variables--
HoursYear and SquareRoot2.
This can be useful if you
forget exactly how you
typed a variable name.
These are our basic building
blocks in R-- functions,
like square root and absolute
value, and variables,
like HoursYear and SquareRoot2.